[Music]
I'd [ __ ] that is not my body now he
took my head
and they make the mistake of putting
that body in front of my real body yeah
that is I think like a 19 year old woman
yeah I don't know would you have wanted
to pose for all laughs course I would
love nothing more than me I'm here to do
the work man they actually thought I was
so lazy that they got someone else's
body well I was out just somewhere doing
coke they put that the drink the drink
anyway let's get into this let's get
into this all right
watching The Handmaid's Tale I was
watching the show The Handmaid's Tale
and I didn't quite know what was going
on so I hit the info button and it said
the first ever TV show created around a
surplus of lampshades Wow thing right
there yeah check this one out Anthony
Bourdain parts unknown yeah and then I
hit the button it said starting that guy
your Aunt Sarah swear she did coke with
in 79 there you go well true look at
this one stranger things
Oh stranger things people love that show
I hit the button and it said takes place
in a town full of weird creepy
happenings like kids entertaining
themselves outdoors I was watching the
show NCIS yes I was watching the show
NCIS and then I hit the little info
button and it said these are the guys in
your grandma's spank bank
[Applause]
I'm sensing an angry crowd right now
Andy the crowd is actually fashioning
weapons on your seats talking dead I was
watching the talking dead yeah when I
hit the button and it said the seventh
show today hosted by Chris Hardwick yeah
I'm gets a lot of work that guy works
constantly he has no interior life
I was watching House Hunters
International yeah I'm gonna hit the
button and it said instead of repairing
their marriage a couple from Wisconsin
says what the hell let's move to
Amsterdam the wall I was watching the
wall and I hit the button it said v8 TV
show today hosted watching dr. Phil cuz
we all do as watching dr. Phil and then
I hit the info button and it said every
day five grueling hours of makeup
transforms comedian Steve Harvey into
America's popular TV therapist
and finally I was watching America's Got
Talent
yeah America's Got Talent
and then I hit the button and it said a
dying nation distracts itself
[Applause]
you